[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey everyone.
It's great to be here.
I'm John McCutchan, a developer
programs engineer at Google.
And my passion is to make
games on the web better.
And I'm going to introduce a
really neat new way to do
that, which is called Native
Client Acceleration Modules.
This is a new concept
that doesn't exist.
But I think it's going to
really make some new
experiences possible
on the web.
So what if you wanted
write most of your
application as a web app?
Meaning you're writing it in
HTML5, you're using JavaScript
or Dart, but there's still
a few sections in your
application where you just can't
extract the performance
out of JavaScript or Dart?
Well, you can get native
performance where you need it
with Native Client Acceleration
Modules, which
allow you to extend your
JavaScript or Dart application
with C++ code.
So right after that, I want to
show you an example Native
Client Acceleration Module.
We have Bullet Physics running
inside an acceleration module,
simulating about 130 rigid
body objects at 60 Hertz.
This is not possible in
the browser today.
But what's interesting here is,
at the front end, all the
graphics that you're seeing
are being drawn by a Dart
application by making
WebGL calls.
The physics simulation is
happening in a separate module
implemented in C that transmits
the updated physics
objects positions to the
Dart application,
which then draws them.
So let me run it here.
You're going to see a whole
bunch of blocks fall on top of
each other, and then some
balls land on them.
Isn't this really
exciting stuff?
I mean, you can't do this
in a browser today.
But you can with Native Client
Acceleration Modules.
So some of you might be asking,
what is Native Client?
I've never heard
of this before.
Well, Native Client allows you
to take your C++ code and
compile it with a version of
GCC which outputs a Native
Client executable and
a manifest file.
This manifest file can be
included in your website with
a single line of HTML code,
which then allows you to
launch an entire C++ application
and have it run in
the browser.
So specifically, Native Client
is a secure C and C++ runtime
for the web.
There's no chance that the C
code could take over someone's
computer or damage it.
It's secured in a sandbox.
But your existing C and C++
code works, along with
languages like C#
through mono.
And these applications interact
with the browser to
take input and draw by
using the Pepper API.
But what makes Native Client
somewhat limited from the
perspective of most web
developers is that it requires
the entire application to be
written in C. So if you want
to get involved with Native
Client, you have to be a C
programmer, which many web
developers aren't.
So can we provide native
performance where it counts,
but make it accessible to
all web app developers?
And yes, Native Client
Acceleration Modules is
exactly that.
It allows you to write most of
your application as an HTML5
application, and communicate
with these very fast C-backed
runtimes that do some
computation for you.
So drilling down a little bit,
we see that the HTML5
application talks to some kind
of JavaScript or Dart library,
which manages the communication
to the back-end
acceleration module.
So if you're a C++ library
author and you want to expose
one of your libraries as an
extension to the browser, how
do you go about doing it?
It's very straightforward.
First, you have to port your
application to Native Client,
which is very straightforward,
because almost all of your C++
code is just going
to compile over.
The only areas where they'll
be any extra work is if you
need to interact with any
Pepper API calls.
But that's a fairly
straightforward port, just
like porting into any other
operating system.
You then expose your C++ API as
an interface of messages.
And what this really means is
that you're going to be doing
a lot of JSON message parsing
and construction.
You could use any communication
mechanism you
want, but JSON is very
convenient because the browser
can consume it trivially.
And because JavaScript
applications execute
asynchronously, you need to add
a work queue to your C++
module where the JavaScript
application can queue some
work for you to do.
You do the work, and then you
send the reply back later on.
Once that's complete, you write
the other side of the
coin, which is a JavaScript or
Dart library, which does the
communication to the Native
Client Acceleration Module.
To give you an idea, it took
me one day to implement the
acceleration module that we saw
earlier, of Bullet Physics.
Just a single day to parse the
messages and construct new
messages to send back
to the browser.
And it was really
straightforward.
So if your web developer and
you want to consume one of
these extensions from a Native
Client Acceleration Module,
how do you go about doing it?
Well, it's really easy and
exactly like you would take
any other JavaScript module
that exists today.
You include the script tag that
references the API that
you're going to be calling.
And the one extra step is that
you include the embed tag for
the Native Client manifest.
Once you've done that, you just
make JavaScript calls as
normal, and they just get
routed in to the C
code in the back end.
But that's invisible to you
as a web app developer.
So it's similar to using
any other JavaScript
library like jQuery.
It's really straightforward.
So what this is going to give us
is, 90% of your application
is going to be a web app, but
you're going to get that
native performance where you
need it, including Bullet
Physics simulating hundreds of
rigid bodies at 60 Hertz,
blazing fast zip decompression,
video encoding
and processing, image
processing, encryption, all of
these very computationally
expensive things that you can
implement in JavaScript, but
you're going to see a big
performance difference between
the native C code.
So now I want to shift gears
and talk about the back-end
implementation of this system.
So you remember this diagram
from earlier, where I'm
showing the HTML5 application
using the JavaScript module
that they've included which is
shunting the messages back and
forth between the Native Client
acceleration module.
What I want to ask is, what are
these messages and how are
they transmitted?
So let's get to it.
All of the messages start with
a message header, which is a
serialized JSON string.
It includes a command name,
a request ID, and then an
arbitrary set of arguments,
depending
on the command itself.
But sometimes these messages are
going to need binary data,
and JavaScript has a mechanism
of accessing binary data
through something called
the Typed Array.
And so after the JSON message
header is sent, subsequently
the n number, where n could be
0, of Typed Arrays are sent
afterwards.
So depending on the format of
the message, there might be
zero Typed Arrays following
the header, or
there could be five.
It's completely up to the
implementer to decide the
optimal way of structuring
these messages.
But they all start with a
header, and then optional set
of Typed Arrays following
that.
So let's give an example.
If I'm a JavaScript app
developer, and I just want to
call this fibonacciAccelerator,
and get
the 10th Fibonacci number, I
make this single call in
JavaScript.
I tell it the nth Fibonacci
number I want, and the
callback that I want
to have fire when
the result is available.
But underneath the hood, what
happens is a command is
structured--
and you can see that the command
is fib, the argument
is 10, and the request
ID is 27.
The request ID is used to
connect the reply that will be
coming later on from
the Native Client
Acceleration Module.
This message gets packaged
up and sent over to the
acceleration module, where the
acceleration module does its
computation and figures
out that the 10th
Fibonacci number is 55.
It then packages up this message
and sends it back to
the JavaScript side, with the
request ID being 27, just like
the original message, so that
you can connect them on the
other side and the correct
call back is fired.
It's a very contrived example,
but this gives you the flavor
of how this operates.
So how are these
messages sent?
Well, they're sent with
calls to postMessage.
And postMessage takes these
messages and it puts them into
a queue that the web application
consumes, or the
Native Client Acceleration
Module consumes.
So I want to talk about
message ordering.
Let's say I have a JSON message
header, and then it
requires three Typed Arrays
following it.
But some other JSON message
header gets in the way.
It gets in the middle.
Question is, is this possible?
And if it is, how can we work
around this problem?
Well, turns out that it is
possible in one specific
configuration, the configuration
of where there's
many Native Client Acceleration
Models embedded
on a page, and they're all
communicating back to the web
application at the same time.
Because there's only one queue
for the entire web
application, what could happen
is that the messages will end
up interleaved between
each other.
And so you'll get some of the
green messages, and then
you'll get the yellow and red
message, and then you'll get
the tail of the green message.
This would be very confusing for
the web application, and
we need to do something
about this.
So what you do is you place a
router between the message
queue and the Native
Client Acceleration
Module JavaScript libraries.
And this router uses the event
source element ID as a way to
route the messages from this
single queue to the specific
JavaScript libraries.
And this solves this problem.
So now I want to talk about the
performance of these messages.
Because if the performance isn't
great, then this is just
not going to work.
But it turns out that the
performance is actually pretty
fast, and will be getting faster
as we move forward.
So what we're looking at here
is a graph of the number of
round trips in five seconds.
A message is being sent from
JavaScript to the Native
Client Acceleration Module,
and then back.
How many times can this happen
in five seconds?
The x-axis is showing you the
message sizes, starting at 16
bytes and ending at 16 megabytes
per message.
And the y-axis is telling you
how many round trips.
So until your message size
hits about 4K, you don't
really see much of a drop off.
It's between 25,000 and 30,000
messages in five seconds.
But after 4K, it starts
to drop off steeply,
but it's only at--
your message size is above 256
kilobytes, that you start to
see the latency go beyond one
millisecond for a round trip.
Another way of looking at the
same set of data is, what's
the throughput?
How much can you push
through this pipe?
And it varies depending
on the message size.
So if you send larger messages,
you get more
throughput.
And it peaks at about 420
megabytes per second.
But once you hit about
640k per message--
sorry, 64k per message,
you get pretty
close to this maximum.
So that's the sweet spot.
If you could package up all your
data for computation and
the results in less than 64k,
you're going to be great.
So I'm going to just pause here
and note that I ran these
benchmarks on a machine running
Chrome 21, Windows 7
with 64-bit, a Core i7 with
12 gigabytes of RAM.
Benchmarking is difficult, and
your operating system and
hardware configuration will give
you different results.
So don't take this as the
absolute truth, but it was
true for my machine.
So the Native Client
Acceleration Module message
system allows for many Native
Client modules on a single
page, which is awesome.
So you, the developer, can mix
and match based on your
application needs.
It offers low latency and high
throughput, which is key.
To make this a little bit more
concrete, I know we looked at
graphs and we saw that
we can transmit 420
megabytes per second.
What does that actually mean?
Well, let's say you wanted to
stream a 1024 by 1024 video at
60 Hertz and just transmit the
entire frame at a time.
So no compression involved, just
60 times a second you're
sending the 1024 by
1024 image across.
Well, that would use 60% of your
bandwidth, at about 240
megabytes per second.
You still lots of room for
other communications
that need to happen.
You'll have an eight millisecond
latency per frame,
which is fine.
Because since we're displaying
at 60 Hertz, eight
milliseconds is actually only
half of the time that you have
to display.
So you won't even be an
entire frame back.
Another example, let's say you
wanted to physically simulate
1,000 rigid bodies.
This is something that
modern CPUs can't
even do at 60 Hertz.
But if they could, you would
be using just 1.7% of your
bandwidth available, with a two
millisecond latency, which
is awesome.
So let's look at some
case studies a
little bit more in depth.
So I showed the video earlier
of the Bullet Physics
acceleration module operating,
communicating its results back
to a Dart application.
But how does this really
work under the hood?
The Dart application sends an
initial message which is, load
this scene.
And the scene includes a
description of all the rigid
bodies in the scene, where you
want them to be, how heavy
they are, how much friction they
have, all these type of
physical properties
that you get.
This gets sent to the Native
Client Acceleration Module,
which remembers the state
of the scene.
Later on, when your application
is ready, it sends
a step simulation message to
the acceleration module.
It says, OK, I want you to
simulate the physics world and
have it update so that it's 16
milliseconds in the future.
It replies back with the set
of transformation matrices
after the simulation
has been updated.
Those transformation matrices
can be fed back into the Dart
application and used to draw the
world as it is, based on
the state of the physics
simulation.
Then this loops.
After we do that, we send
another message back to the
Native Client Acceleration
Modules saying update the
simulation.
We get the new transforms
and we draw it.
And we just keep looping.
So let's look at the performance
of a Native Client
Acceleration Module built
around Bullet, to
machine-translated JavaScript.
So for those of you who
aren't familiar with
machine-translated JavaScript,
there are tools out there that
will take a C or C++ Program and
compile it to JavaScript,
which is pretty awesome.
But how does the performance
compare when you're executing
that JavaScript that was
generated by the tool, versus
a Native Client Acceleration
Module?
Well, what the graph we're
looking at here, the x-axis is
frames, the y-axis is
microseconds to update the
simulation state.
So red is the JavaScript
execution time, blue is the
Native Client Acceleration
Module.
You probably notice you don't
see a lot of blue, and that's
because the performance
difference is so large that
blue is just essentially at 0.
I'll zoom in a moment and show
you the true difference
between them.
But what's interesting about
this graph is you see these
two huge spikes where the
JavaScript is just like, even
for its own baseline
performance, is many times
slower for these moments.
And so the question is,
what's causing this?
And it's difficult to nail down
exactly what's causing
it, but there's two
likely causes.
The first is, JavaScript is a
garbage collected language.
So after a certain amount of
time, enough garbage--
which is objects that are
no longer referenced--
accumulates.
And what happens is the
JavaScript runtime stops the
execution of the program, it
goes in and collects all this
garbage, frees it, and makes it
available for future use.
But what that means is that if
that garbage collection kicks
in in the middle of your physics
simulation, you're
going to see a huge spike
in the time it takes
to update the world.
Another cause is that, because
JavaScript is a JIT engine,
what it does is it initially
outputs unoptimized code.
And then it collects statistics,
like every time
this function gets called, the
first argument is a string.
And then it outputs optimized
code based around that
assumption.
But what's inside that optimized
code is checks that
that assumption is true.
The moment that assumption is
not true, it pulls a parachute
out, and it goes back to
the non-optimized code.
So what we're seeing with these
two spikes could either
be really extreme moments of
JavaScript garbage collection,
or some assumption is being
broken, and everything is
getting de-optimized and
then re-optimized.
Eventually it stabilizes.
And when we zoom in, we can
actually see the execution
time for the Native Client
Acceleration Module.
In this specific example, it's
about 100 microseconds per
frame update, and you could
see that it's very steady.
Whereas the JavaScript update
is 1,000 microseconds, or an
order of magnitude slower,
with these weird spikes.
I mean, this is even--
this was noise on the image that
we were just looking at a
moment ago.
But you can still see that
every once in a while,
JavaScript performance goes from
1,000 microseconds per
frame update to 2,000
or 4,000.
It's very bumpy.
You never see this kind of
variation with the Native
Client Acceleration Module.
So what about download size?
These are web applications and
this is really important.
If the JavaScript performance
is not that great, but it
takes only a fraction of the
time to download than the
Native Client Acceleration
Module, maybe that trade-off
is worth making.
So looking at the uncompressed
sizes, the acceleration module
is a 3 megabyte download, and
the machine-generated
JavaScript is 2 megabytes.
So we're looking at about 66% of
the acceleration module to
download the JavaScript.
Compressed, it gets a
little bit better.
It gets close to about two times
the download size for
the acceleration module to
one JavaScript module.
So again, this really comes down
to what's important here.
If you have very light load
and you can get away with
using the JavaScript
code, good.
That's awesome.
Because it's going download
a little bit faster.
But if you have something
really heavy, where this
really matters, where it counts,
when you need that
native performance, the overhead
is not that big.
So let's look at another
case study.
Let's say you want to be able to
zip and unzip things inside
your web application.
There are implementations of
this in JavaScript, but again,
as we'll see, the performance
is just--
it can't be matched.
So the Native Client
Acceleration Modules for the
compressor and at the
decompressor are stateless.
They're kind of dumb.
They just accept a message.
They take the compressed
data and then they
decompress it and--
sorry, they take the compressed
data, and they
compress it, and they send that
back to you as a message.
The decompressor works
similarly.
You give it the compressed blob,
and it sends back an
uncompressed blob.
It's very simple.
These acceleration modules
have no state.
They don't really know
what's going on.
They just do one thing, and
they do it really well.
But what's great about the
acceleration model framework
is that you can include both of
these on your page and send
them a message whenever
you need to.
So let's look at the
performance again.
Again you can see that the
JavaScript implementation
executes about an order of
magnitude slower than the
Native Client Acceleration
Module does.
And again, you see that very
rocky performance.
It's not as consistently--
the performance is just like,
sometimes it's fast, sometimes
it's slow with JavaScript.
Whereas with the Native Client
Acceleration Module, it's much
more stable.
And looking at decompression
times, again you can see that
the Native Client implementation
is far faster
than the JavaScript execution.
So what am I saying about
machine-translated JavaScript?
Well first of all, it works,
and it works really well.
Depending on your needs,
it might be a great
solution for you.
It's pretty amazing that you
could take a C++ program and
get a working JavaScript
program out of it.
It's kind of mind blowing.
But what I'm really showing
with this performance
comparison is the difference
in execution time for a
JavaScript JIT engine versus
native code running in the
Native Client sandbox.
So that being said, Native
Client Acceleration Modules
are an order of magnitude faster
than the JavaScript
equivalents, and they offer
consistent performance.
And for interactive applications
like a physics
simulation, system performance
is key.
If there's a frame that's four
times slower than the previous
frame, it really gets
weird and the
experience is just not there.
So wrapping up, I first want to
talk about some concerns.
So one, currently Native
Client is only
available in Chrome.
But as I've shown,
machine-translated JavaScript
can offer the same
functionality, but just at a
performance penalty.
So for web browsers that don't
have Native Client yet, you
can fall back to the
machine-translated JavaScript
implementation.
Another concern, it's early.
There's no shipping
acceleration modules out there.
There's just some prototypes
and a bunch of sample code.
But this is the perfect
time to help out.
You can help make
this a reality.
So the third concern is that
there are certain classes of
applications, maybe a
spreadsheet, where if you need
to keep all of the cells in the
web app side and all of
the cells in the Native Client
side, or constantly be
communicating back and forth
with each other, the
performance gains here are not
going to be as drastic as
we're seeing.
But the Native Client
Acceleration Module framework
is really designed
for these, like--
90% of your application is a web
app, 10% of it needs to be
really fast, and you want it
to run in a Native Client
Acceleration Module.
So Native Client Acceleration
Modules are going to allow us
to bring new types of
experiences to the web, things
that you can do today, but you
can't do it fast enough to
make it a great experience.
The usage for you as a web
developer is really
straightforward.
It's just like including any
other JavaScript library.
You don't have to worry about
the C implementation or
anything like that.
It's taken care for you.
You just make some function
calls in JavaScript and it
works really fast.
So 90% web app, native
performance where you need it.
That's what you're going to
get with Native Client
Acceleration Modules.
So, to do--
you've got to go and get
the Native Client SDK.
You can get that from going
to www.gonacl.com.
Clone an example Native Client
Acceleration Module.
You can get that from
the URL there.
It's coming out of my github.
You could take that and use
that as the base to start
writing your own.
And join the discussion.
Participate in the mailing list
and start talking with
other people who are
implementing Native Client
Acceleration Modules, and
come up with better
ways of doing this.
Thank you.
I'm John McCutchan.
You can read my blog at
johnmccutchan.com or find me
on Google+.
Check out all the code
I read on github or
check me out on Twitter.
Thank you.